they've their reject notion more name is
shir and I'm hard and I can't do a very
good Dwayne Johnson impersonation but
you took Jason Statham it's to you and
you won Julian all I could do
I'm also buffer than you though so this
that helps my case actually I can't even
do a good Jason Statham the best I could
do is my name's Jeb Chelios
I feel like diaster died that I'd die
Jason Statham is you just got big rough
embrace your weeaboo graffiti bridge and
you know talks is sort of his advice hey
I can do martial arts terrible terrible
bad impression that Dragons you on today
any we're gonna watch fast and furious
percent lead the universe expansion we
were all asking for yep the two people
the family arguably should have trusted
the least Oh before we do that I wanted
to say special thanks to everyone who
has been downloading and following us on
the Stardust app over there we do thirty
second reaction reviews for films TV
shows and trailers to want to get our
opinions early on things or for things
that we haven't covered on YouTube you
go check us out over there sometimes or
even micro sketches free to download
free to use due to die do it today
this is gonna be crazy bad
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
what does he is upgraded Wow oh my god
Wow
you know gosh I'm just I I'm so happy
I'm so happy I can't I can't wait to
watch this is so ridiculous it is
refreshing every once in a while to see
a trailer and just know that some
producer was just like yep put whatever
you want in there I don't care just do
whatever get some guns because the cars
blow some things up break some glass run
down a building you think you know doing
a spin-off with Hobbes and Shaw would
you minimize the like some of the
enthusiasm of the ridiculous this is
somehow franchise it as a huge ensemble
it's only gonna get more ridiculous and
it's only gonna wink at you bigger for
doing I love its commitment to it though
I love it and you know what else I
really love is because you know when you
think of The Fast and the Furious movies
which I do all the time I think of it
too much yeah what do you think of those
movies you know it's like you want the
returning players to be there you want
Vin Diesel in the rock to show up in the
movies sure Danna Brewster yeah and her
too you want them to show up but you
don't really think about like ah you
know I'm really I'm really showing up
for the chemistry and all that and where
their characters have gone yeah her time
with this not only am I so excited
[ __ ] silly his all looks how crazy
this is but I genuinely got excited for
I am so looking forward to watching
these two interact like their banter
back and forth that that moment they're
just saying exactly the same thing about
each other yeah and they're two
different sides of the same coin in a
way it was so delightful and just you're
like god this is business I'm completely
sold on this movie because you know like
the fate of the Furious that was a movie
that I felt got started taking it up a
little too serious at times of fate of
the Serie of fate of this serious man
you might say I did yeah John John said
that and then when he kept to this movie
you're like how this this is bringing it
right back to where I wanted and even
more because yeah I'm excited to see
their chemistry and the the laws of
physics are you back bro
way more out the window than ever before
and this whole thing would address Elba
being a superhuman character after how
serious and like you know dramatic fate
of the Furious wanted to get it I guess
it is refreshing to see them go and like
double down in the opposite direction of
just like no no no it's gonna be fun and
craziness and set pieces and eat
yourself is gonna be a character from a
GI Joe movie yeah like this could have
been the sequel to both of those yeah is
his costume aesthetic especially it
looks like that
and I mean they don't give you much to
go off of with him just that beginning
sequence for the light Arthur soldier
the future something technology and
we're showing Holograms and stuff and
then you know on the bad guy and the
movie just seems like it that's the
element I'm most curious about because
it seems like they've really approached
this with a meta edge where they're like
acknowledging a lot of very self-aware
yeah self-aware beats and stuff like
that which could work I'm curious about
it just because it seems like they're
boldly leading with that sense of humor
I mean it's it's kind of it's cool
because it's a Hello I would say fast
and furious presents where's Roman
reigns in this transient
yeah that's like a big talk right yeah
you're from and rains we're on VC
Vanessa Kirby in here yeah that was
great and fallout yeah it's a sequel to
Mission Possible
in some kind of like it looks like
they're Chernobyl or something and
they're running down buildings and just
like there's even seem to have breathing
issues Hobbes become like a superhuman
dick would Dave Alicia's Direction that
I love because you know he came onto the
scene with John wick yeah which was a
pretty serious movie and then he went on
to do Deadpool - any pretty serious
pretty serious movie well it seems like
he's taken a lot of cues out of that
film specifically because a lot of this
seems more like Deadpool - if anything
than it does like John wick oh yeah I
was really kind of going and expecting
more of a John wick like oh we're gonna
get a trailer with like some really cool
action in the rock Jesus and I'm gonna
be super serious but I love it they've
really doubled down on the comedy man
I'm excited for it I really am very
excited for it because their interplay
looks so delightful oh yeah I mean these
two dudes are just so much fun to watch
together and like as weird as this kind
of is for The Fast and the Furious
franchise overall and to slap that and
it's a Fast and the Furious represents
after there's been so much controversy
between the cast about the existence of
this movie it does seem like a sequel of
this sort especially nowadays does kind
of thrive on being self-aware and
over-the-top to a point that everybody
is aware of what's happening so I feel
like you're able to circumvent the whole
life this is the seventh movie we've
done or the ninth movie or whatever you
know I kind of I kind of feel like like
scrolling through these comments that I
just started through right now I feel
like saying fast and furious presents is
actually working against them because a
lot of people are like wait a minute
where's Vin Diesel yeah I think I think
especially when you say fast and furious
in the title it actually is kind of
working against them right now
yeah I think it's gonna compete like I
feel like for a movie audience like
people like us who follow movie news and
are aware what it knows so we're doing
whatever won't be lost but III kind of
think that was not the smartest call on
their end
yeah I wonder cuz it doesn't seem like
they're short on marketing money so I
feel like they could have got the word
out about Hobbes and Shaw it's the big
like fast and furious on the biggest
franchise in the world at the moment so
a lot of people know those two
characters so I don't feel like it would
be hard to raise awareness about just
calling it Hobson well I think I think
st. Fast and Furious presents and the
trailer would have been fine as opposed
to putting it in the title title of it
is I think people are gonna be kind of
confused and be like yo where's the rest
of the cast I'm like guys yeah yeah
anywho yeah well this looks like a
really fun movie I'm excited to check it
out he loves buildings the rock loves
building I was very much excited to
check this out yeah all right well you
guys can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell what do you
think about Hobbes and Shaw and download
and falls on the start us up today
baitball